good morning nerdfighters it's actually
not morning but it will be and I will
still be awake that is a promise I am
right now participating in the blogtv
Ironman and Sami ecology in which I have
several other awesome youtubers and one
awesome blog deavere Argo oh my chair
sometimes this chair goes back sometimes
it doesn't it surprised me we were going
to be staying for as long as we possibly
can the previous Ironman have something
a challenge went for 40 hours we crab
and I can't promise that but I will
promise you that I'm going to be online
on blogtv link in the sidebar for as
long as this video is online so if you
are watching this video I will be on
pond TV so you'll get to see what it
looks like when I do work which is
probably pretty boring but I also be
doing other interesting things for
example there will be a cameo at some
point in the process by my friend will
who is the best breakdancer in Missoula
I am not kidding and he may very well
bust out on my very own concrete floor
of my very own living room and you don't
want to miss that I may also read some
from Paper Towns I may also spend over
six hours adding Facebook friends
because that would be one with a stamp
really really late
just click confirm confirm confirm
confirm complete that's not something
that requires a great deal of mental
agility adding Facebook friends I could
probably do it until next Tuesday if you
wanna be my facebook friend and give me
something to do during my blog TV
insomnia challenge you can go to paper
Tom's comm and click on my head think my
jobs video will be online tonight he's
going to be in Chicago tonight hopefully
you got tickets I will see you guys I'm
baack TV I want to have more viewers
than shaycarl even gonna see you just
like mute it and leave it on I want to
have more viewers than shake off so just
mute it and leave it on and I'll be like
haha Jake Carlile viewers about TV than
you I will see you up on TV